they're having to choose which fires to
fight here
one of the biggest burnt through acres
of this national park
surrounding an athens suburb
camping residents ordered to evacuate
watched on helplessly
the entire forest is burning look and
the heat
coming from the fire is so strong
everything is burning
people could save themselves but little
else business owners returning
to see what was left of their
livelihoods
the fire department put out the fire at
eight but then suddenly at ten it
reignited we don't know how
and the two factories next to my
building were burnt
in the cryoneery area 12 miles north of
athens
a children's play park is barely
recognizable
this is the worst heat wave to hit
greece in 30 years
and flames swept through streets burning
cars
coming perilously close to these homes
a few people have returned now the fire
has been contained but most haven't
and in part that's because many homes
here are now without
power without water but it's mainly
because
temperatures and winds are set to rise
again in the coming days and that could
see
this fire flare up again the threat is
still high here
firefighters from across europe are
sending help
this unit deploying from bonn in germany
and at least
20 officers from the uk are supporting
the effort too
in turkey fires have burned out of
control for ten days
forcing thousands to flee
and fires now in southern italy have
triggered a state of emergency in sicily
greek and european officials blaming
many of the fires on climate change
the ecosystems that have been destroyed
is a very big issue for us
because as you know we are a country
that is suffering and will suffer for
from heat
and drought so our our most important
shield is our forests
and losing forests for us is devastating
and will have
a great impact in our ability to
to to to adapt and to shield ourselves
from
climate change these are unsettling
scenes on the eve of a big climate
report by the ipcc
their findings delivered in the backdrop
of ferocious fires
burning in southern europe and beyond
sally lockwood sky news
athens